hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I see you I
see where's my portal third oh hello
you can press e to interact with and
pick up certain objects most rooms have
locked doors that can be only open by
picking up a key okay
so basically this game is kind of in the
same style as I'm scared
a pixelated nightmare I think it was
inspired by it actually I'm not sure and
I kind of feel like I've been getting
away from the indie horror games
focusing on stuff like slender the
arrival and other stuff like that so I
wanted to get back into it so expect a
lot more indie horror games in the very
near future okay so I am looking for a
key of some sort it's a pretty familiar
of mechanicing various different horror
games
zot a key that's some heat once you grab
a key a door will become unlocked all
unlock doors have been marked for you
well that's convenient how will I know
where they are though and I haven't seen
any door besides the exit one I doubt
that is that the marker is at something
else all right
a big blood red X on the door sounds
good to me let's
and ending daily Looney kucik some areas
have doors that are unlocked for you not
that one not that one either
alright then depress shift to run but
you can never get away from what get
away from why alright then
not exactly sure what that was all about
but it definitely was unsettling haha so
there's apparently something else in
this hospital question mark seems like
an insane asylum more than a hospital
whatever it is I'm guessing that it sees
me have I been in here oh man I don't
like this I don't like this much at all
I do not care for this it's definitely
given me a sense of apprehension I got a
key but how I know which door got
unlocked I have no idea I don't even
know what my objective is really it gave
me plenty of tutorials but nothing much
else besides that let's just hurry on up
just whatever I'm gearing up actually
let me check some of the doors down here
maybe you nope okay
whatever sign here is probably getting
closer and closer to my current location
the only way to move forward is to man
the hell up and move forward
what a lovely painting I have nothing
else nice to say about this entire place
hello you're gonna jump out at me do it
sooner rather than later I don't like
waiting around to be scared okay just
double checking every time I go down a
long hallway I always assume that as
soon as I turn around they're gonna get
me ah hello this wand is already
unlocked okay so I only need to check
the doors with the big red X on them
then again this might be a trap too so
what was that what was that I saw
something like a doorbell hello this is
something in here oh yeah that's not a
trap
you can also use you can hide all you
want but I will find you you big mood
why God couchy do my little crotchy
dance okay
ah okay nothing was scary UM's don't
like standing I don't like walking
slowly down a hole with them
what the hell ah blood ah what the hell
what the hell what the hell man the
freaking frack this is not right
I guess I'll follow the blood for some
stupid reason
hello squeak ah just a shadow nothing to
be concerned about
hi mr. shadow man I'm coming after you
I'm gonna get ya
I'm marking the doors for you why Hey
look blood Hey look more blood
why ah the exit key good good now I can
go home baby
like I said ash I assume long hallways
are gonna be the death of me I don't
like a hollow mommy No thank you little
girl I've learned to ignore any calls
from little girls in any horror game ha
ha ha
press e to interact with and pick up sir
knobbed wait most rooms I've locked door
that can only be opened when I want them
to be you need to stop [ __ ] with me
guy stop being such an a-hole I have the
what is that hahahahaha you can hear me
no thank you I don't want any I'd like
to go home that's okay with you ha ha
egg in our teeth and I oh I saw that
something red oh no not another one of
these rooms a John Turner
okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay
I'm okay I'm not dead yet
ah exit set the exercise what's good a
bird that's alright
good for you Oh
ah
they wore what the hell man what the
hell what is that ah ah it hurts okay
don't go in there I may be going there I
don't know I'm so confused
oh look another one I'm not going in
there or maybe I should here we go ah
okay don't go in there
that is a portal to a demonic realm of
which I know thank you
key yeah key
I have key what do I do with key are
there even any other doors that he's
gonna let you open
uh-huh yes I'm gonna die very very soon
how much go away please
go away please go away please ah what
the hell was that hello hello anybody in
here
I heard someone I heard like a little
girl then again I've been hearing a
little girl
throughout the game hello
okay now we're gonna get into the
kick-ass music alright alright I can dig
it it's got a nice beat okay I still
can't tell if this is a mental hospital
or just a regular normally hospital
maybe it's a retirement home a really
messed up retirement home I can't
believe I haven't been like thoroughly
lost yet because I've been doing a fatal
error has occurred oh that's what you
mean by fatal Oh
oh I see and I I'm sorry I won't touch
your eye oh there's another one oh this
is that one's really open okay
all right there's something special
about this eye that I'm supposed to take
note of or something I don't know but
now the walls are covered in blood and
eyes oh okay I thought it was just gonna
be complete silence thank goodness for
the doom music oh what the hell
someone's speaking Italian hey I saw you
I'm coming after you you [ __ ]
don't you think you can mess with me oh
my goodness
oh my you let them out oh lordy Lou ah
ha ha ha ha ha ah what is this case from
what I'll sound demonic butthole oh my
god
okay I'm out of here
I got a key I just scream out of and
then they go away that's what I do I can
scream louder than they can what the
whoa what the hell what's going on here
what is this what's happen
ah okay good yeah that's top oh yeah
okay that's normal
I'm back in the morgue now haha oh okay
alright you just the room is filling
with blood that's great
okay on gear or has kicker cannot a lot
next a rewarm that's more blood okay
let's get let's bring it on fill it up
with blood see if I care
uh-huh uh-huh oh that's not blood that's
that red goop that was oh boy
hey did I get a virus what sort of porn
did I look out to get this oh my this is
lovely
um
charmed I'm sure but uh
what the hell ha ha ha ah I think my
graphics card it might be screwed up
just a little bit here what the hell
this is so trippy and weird everything
is just completely wrong here oh boy oh
boy man
this seriously isn't amazing in the
organ this is an incredible sang that
right now this is like right up there
with I'm scared this is Pacey can I get
through here wait maybe oh my god I feel
like I might be breaking the game if I
tried it before sex oh let's not ha ha
ha
where do I even go I don't even know
now I hear more girls and guys screaming
in background let's just move forward
and hope that something returns to some
kind of normalcy maybe not I see an exit
sign
probably just false hope ah
uh huh huh okay things have kind of
calmed down a bit I bet there's nothing
in these rooms
my friend hasn't spoken to me in a while
oh haha oh that's so disturbing that's
so creepy it's so friggin weird ha hi
can I help you with some I don't need an
eye exam uh uh uh okay I guess isn't ah
okay yeah
okay that was really weird you didn't
see that because it opened in my other
window but uh maybe it's best if you
don't cuz that was a cool ending to the
deal so hah hah hah hah hah hah so
anyway that is amazing you guys have to
try that and see the ending for yourself
because it's really only worth it if you
actually see the ending for yourself so
please do give it a try that's an
amazing game absolutely incredible
probably the best one I played in a long
time give it a try so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotations
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
nah
I got it